let's make kimchi queso with seaweed
chips mmm
first thing we're gonna make is a rice
paper seaweed chip this is the rice
paper I'm using this is the seaweed I'm
using all right first step we're going
to dip the rice paper in water we're
gonna shake off any excess water seaweed
sheet press it until they both stick
okay one sheet makes about six chips so
estimate how much you need I'm going to
bake it in the oven until it's dry
enough to fry okay after a few minutes
in the oven you want your seaweed rice
paper to be like this it's still pliable
but it's dry cut in smaller pieces fry
your chips
okay now I'm gonna lightly season this
with salt and black pepper to make the
dip milk cochicado if you want it spicy
you can also use cayenne and we're gonna
add cheddar smoked gouda or whatever
cheese you like honestly sour cream
then we're gonna add the kimchi now that
looks ready